In dynamic programming, this happens to be really easy to program--
even easier than in A-star. Here is how I did it.
I defined a field called "policy" of the same size as my grid,
initialized it with lots of spaces.
Now in my dynamic programming procedure
check for whether we have reached the goal state, and we have.
Then I set the corresponding element to star,
using a single new command that just sets policy [x, y] to star.
Finally, in my big update loop where I assign an improved value to a grid cell [x, y]
based on its successor, I assign to the policy the character
that corresponds to the action that led to that update over here.
Put differently, as we look for a better value we look into all possible directions
by looping over all actions.
If one of those succeeds, I just memorize in my policy function what that action was
with a command over here.
If I finally know output this, then I get this field over here.